Because Brother machines pre-select needles
prior to knitting, we can check our stitch
pattern and the position of the pattern
on the needle bed. Without any yarn
pass the carriage to examine
the needle position.
In this example we'll look at the first
few rows, start with enough needles in
work to accommodate the stitch pattern
repeat.
This is stitch pattern #90
and it's a 24 stitch repeat.
So I've put 60 needles
into working position.
The pattern is set for an all-over design.
It will repeat across the needlebed.
Keep in mind that by default it will be
centered on the needle bed in this case,
needles 1 through 12,
left and right of the imaginary 0.
With the change knobs
set to KC (I) or KC (II)
take the carriage all the way out past
the turn mark,
then pass the carriage across the needles.
I've double-checked and it's these needles
that we'll be for the heel of the boot
and they've been selected.
Needles number 5 through 11
and there are repeats across the bed.
Pass the carriage back for row 2
and confirm that these needles
are selected. On row 3
Again, read your pattern and you should
be able to see that these
needles are selected.
Can you see the value in dry knitting?
No
guesswork. You know where the patterning is
going to occur even before
threading up the machine.